I need an emergency assistance the Wind  River Indian Reservation I'm June banner  okay welcome to Wyoming by yourself it's  just me that's Cory Lambert this is  where I found the body this is a  homicide I knew that girl he's a fighter  they have six officers to cover an area  the size of Rhode Island maybe you can  help I know what the tracks say what is  it that you do again odd fitters so why  don't you come hunt one for me then  why would a teenage girl be out here  what's she running from you looking for  clues but you missed a null science  shouldn't we wait for backup this isn't  lend the backup Jane this is a land of  you're on your own  oh my god you won't get the answers  you're looking for no matter what you  find why wouldn't your daughter run from  home I don't know why you didn't tell me  you you cannot blink not ever this place  what it takes from us but it took from  you Sydney  locked on them out here  [Music]  [Music]